disney is introducing
a hundred dollar sandwich so when i
heard this story i said you got to be
kidding me
disneyland's introducing 100 sandwich as
a fox business story yes
what's the sandwich look like so here's
what it is real quick we'll spend two
minutes on this disney reserve will come
out
uh soon and they're opening up anaheim
california resort will have a new panini
sandwich that will be debuting when
avenge
avengers campus opens at disneyland
adventures on june 4th
the sandwich has an eye popping price
tag of 100
to be fair to sand which is meant to be
eaten by more than one person
so what's in the sandwich that cost this
much money it comes with salami
rosemary ham provolone and sun-dried
tomato spread on toasted
focaccia and focaccia and
can feed up to eight people the sandwich
will also be available in single serving
of 15 bucks can we see what the sandwich
looks like can you imagine a hundred
dollar sandwich in disneyland it does
look it's a panini
yeah i don't know i just kind of feel
like i'm so at this point i'm getting
hungry and hungry it's 10 30.
and i thought that was a quick story
yeah any thoughts on that i have some
thoughts
i'm looking forward to their very
controversial story here so i'm looking
forward to their 435
chicken nugget i mean i heard that is
amazing they also have a 200
hot dog bun but here's my favorite the
130 dollar parking fee
oh wait they already have that you know
it totally makes it
really well it feels like that when you
go there how much is it actually
can i give everybody the secret to do it
disney yes you learned this when you
live down there
go to downtown disney right where the
bars are you know where the restaurants
are
valet right okay and then just go in and
have a drink before you walk into
disneyland so you can dilute the pain a
little bit that you're gonna feel
walking around with your kids for the
next couple hours
that's our strategy valet park drink
before you go in and then it makes it a
lot more enjoyable by the way i think
it's a brilliant idea to have a hundred
dollar sandwich
because it takes the sting off the
increased ticket prices the 12
bottle of water it just skews
perspective how much is tickets right
now disneyland probably
what 100 i would imagine maybe even more
right yeah
i mean they got to make up for some lost
time anybody knows that kai do you have
an idea or no adam you
i know you're big on that so are you you
got disneyland ticket prices or no
i'm saying 150 bucks yeah what is it by
the way i'm actually curious at this
point
i think it's like 159 bucks if you ask
me i don't know why i think it's 159
there it is okay
104 it's the price is for a number of
days
one day is 104. what are you looking at
it's
one day tier five one park per day okay
104 dollars okay not a bad price if you
ask me
not about 98 a child okay that's what's
expensive right there but
90 dollars a child you got a couple kids
i'll tell you what i'd rather do a 72
haircut than 100 sandwiches any day of
the week wow would you really though
yeah so you mean to tell me you wouldn't
want to have a hundred dollar panini
with kai
[Laughter]
you wouldn't want to do that with your
boys that's a man witch right that's a
man witch right there i'm good
on that so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye